the University of Kentucky is launching
a new beginner Farmers training program
alongside the Pike County Cooperative
Extension Service the program is
designed to properly introduce new
Farmers to the agricultural industry and
help them build their skills and network
with other Farmers best of all it's
completely free to those interested this
is a training program for brand new
Farmers so if you're uh you know say
fresh out of college or you know they
said it's good something for veterans or
just anybody that's a very new
interested in commercial farming this is
something that uh it's excellent
opportunity lots of Hands-On workshops
help you with marketing um anything
vegetable small fruit production
livestock it's excellent for for New
farmers if you're especially if you're
within you know one to three years just
now beginning this is an excellent
opportunity for for that kind of person
journey into the extraordinary Blast Off
from any of our three locations Co run
keny or South Williamson Hideway novelty
smoke and vape farmers will also receive
one-on-one mentoring sessions so they
can receive proper feedback applications
are due February 1st they're looking for
someone who is focused and very serious
about commercial farming um any anyone
who is willing to put in the hours and
put in the work and take advantage of
this uh training program like I said
it's a wonderful opportunity for anybody
that that's willing to uh put in the
hours and participate they will provide
oneon-one business marketing training
anything related to commercial
production or vegetables or livestock
and the taken field trips you can go and
um Mentor a farmer um really really uh
help you get started and and help you in
uh
farming reporting for Mountaintop news
I'm Nick Colum